المدن ما حولها وما ضمها مدينه غازي عنتاب
اصبت بدمار كبير بسبب الزلزال والزلازل
التي تلتها منها
امس قمت بزياره بعض المدن هنا من ضمنها
المدن الاخرى
النتائج الاخيره التي حصلنا عليها
شخص اما على الاشجار
67,99 شخص تقريبا
في الجوار اعمال الانقاذ اعمال الانقاذ
مستمره وعمليات
تستمر على قدم وساق في مدينه غازي عنتاب
عدد مباني انهارت بشكل كبير وتقريبا وصل
عددها الى اكثر من 900 مبنى تعرض لي
الانهيار
علينا ان نتحدث
عنه
الارواح كل ما توفي فيها
ان يرفع عنا هذا البلاء طبعا نحن في
مؤسسات في المؤسسات الحكوميه
والوزارات هناك عدد كبير من الموظفين
الموجودين هنا
يشاركون في عمليات البحث والانقاذ هناك
جهود
كما ذكرنا سابقا
ان الهدف الاساسي هنا اعاده اعمار المدينه
في اقصر وقت ممكن وخلال عام تقريبا سيتم
اكمال اعاده بناء المدينه واعاده بناء
المباني السكنيه وطبعا سيتم تشخيص كل
الاضرار في هذه المدن والان في هذه
المرحله الان
سيتم تقديم 10,000 ليره تركيه لكل اسره
وهذه المساعدات ستكون نقديه لكل اسره في
منطقه وفي العشر مدن المنكوبه طبعا هذه
المبالغ ستساهم فقط في تقليل
المالي
على هذه الاسر طبعا هناك اعمال في انشاء
العمل على انشاء المخيمات وايضا الحاويات
السكنيه
المتحركه تتواجد هنا ويتم العمل على
استقبال عدد كبير من الحاويات من الدول
الاخرى ومن المدونه الاخرى لتوزيعها على
المدن وطبعا هناك اعمال على
ايصال عدد كبير من الى هذه المنطقه
وطبعا اكبر عدد ممكن من المواطنين
وطبعا نرى ان في هذه
الاثناء مع الاسف
محاولات الاستغلال هذه الازمه لمصالح
سياسيه طبعا نحن لن نسمح ولا المواطن الذي
يسمحوا لهذه الاستغلالات ولن يسقط اذا هذه
الاستغلالات السياسيه طبعا كما تعلمون
هناك اعلان لحاله الطوارئ واليوم
يتم تبرير هذا القانون وسيتم اعلانه من
قبل البرلمان التركي والذي ثلاثه اشهر
رئيس الجمهوريه
اتخذت هذه الخطوه
من البرلمان التركيه يتم اعلانه بشكل واضح
وليبدا بالتنفيذ ماذا
ستلي
هذا القرار سيتم
معاقبه كل
التجار الذين
الاسعار ويستغلون هذه الازمه
لزياده ارباحهم ماليا كما سيتم ملاحقه كل
الاسواق والمراكز التجاريه ويسرق منها
السلع
هذه قايره
متابعتها وطبعا
سيتم
هؤلاء مباشر
[موسيقى]
والانقاذ وكل من يدعم تركيا وندعم
المواطنين الذين يدعمون العمليات هنا بشكل
مباشر نشكر الجميع طبعا اللام
نحن كنا متواجدين في مدينه تيفان واستطعم
ان نتغلب على المصائب هناك
جدا وجميع يعلم
الافاده التي تلتها والحاله التي دلتها
وايضا استطعنا ان نتغلب على
الكارثه في ازمير ايضا استطعنا ان نبني
منازل ونسلمها الى اصحابها بعد الزلزال
لذلك يجب علينا ان نتضمن ونعمل بشكل سريع
وان نعوض
المعتز بمنازل اخرى شكرا جزيلا